once upon a time it was rare to see a
character straight up return from the
dead existing in narrative limbo under a
shroud of host story ambiguity like what
happened to Breaking Bad's Walter
White's or Tony Soprano and The Sopranos
sure but to come entirely back that was
highly unlikely it was even less likely
in action films like The Fast and the
Furious franchise which don't
necessarily lend themselves to the same
high concept rule bending universe
building of science fiction fantasy and
superhero genres and yet the first
trailer for the ninth Fast & Furious
movie out nineties just that the final
few seconds of the trailer effectively
rose fan-favorite character Han from the
grave odd made his first appearance in
The Fast franchise in 2006's The Fast
and the Furious Tokyo Drift
the same film in which he was believed
to have died in a fiery car crash and
the f9 trailer he's seen walking through
a corridor snack in hand as always and
then there's this nice Club us whoa
that's unexpected the big reveal has
many fans excited and it should because
Hans returned to the Fast and Furious
film series is due in large part to them
in a recent interview with Entertainment
Weekly f9 director Justin Lin explained
that after he departed from The Fast
franchise back in 2013 a new story idea
coupled with comments from hardcore fans
inspired him to come back bringing his
longtime collaborator and Han actor Sung
Kang with him he told E W I would travel
and just meet people and fans of the
franchise and they would tell me why
they loved the franchise so much and
just share their stories and along the
way I hadn't seen the other two movies
and I was at a Q&A for better luck
tomorrow when someone brought up justice
for pod and so all these things were
kind of working together the justice for
Han hashtag was started by fans angry
over the franchise's decision to turn
former fast and furious bill at Deckard
Shaw into an ally of Dom Toretto's crew
before then giving him and lucas hobbs a
2019 spin-off in the 6th past
installment Shaw was revealed to be
behind Hans presumed death in Tokyo
Drift
oddly enough on zap 9 appearance will
basically serve as his second
resurrection and in 2016 interview with
e-w celebrating the 10th anniversary of
Tokyo Drift
both lin and actor Sung Kang said the
story of the Nomad
silent observer with deep pockets
actually goes all the way back to the
directors first feature film in Fast
Five it's established that the name Han
Solo with sole spelled like the capital
of South Korea is an alias and an
obvious reference the Han Solo from Star
Wars Lin subsequently confirmed in
various interviews that Han is actually
a continuation of hot Lou the
chain-smoking partier with a moral
compass from his 2002 independent crime
drama better luck tomorrow based on the
real-life 1992 Honor Roll slain the film
follows a group of high achieving Asian
American high school students who swap
suburban boredom for a school-wide
cheating operation that takes a dark
turn LAN and Kang have grown alongside
this character which is why when the
director departed from the franchise it
felt right to finally let the character
go
but now Lin is saying that both he and
Han have unfinished business and the
flashy Fast and Furious universe he told
the W in January 2020 when I left I felt
it was appropriate and I felt like we
were putting the character to bed but
it's because of some of the things that
happened that didn't quite make sense to
me and so I felt like if I was going to
come back I really wanted to explore why
it's still unclear how exactly Han will
make his return but we'll know soon
enough
f9 races in the theaters on May 22nd
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]